that sounds like your relationship with
Chip Kelly Tina Road yeah like we really
could have been Superbowl would you say
it out loud if you say Victor Shaw
Jackson Jeremy Maclin will show off
McCoys and sell like that offensive line
that had studs yours was there to hurts
baby arts what is it like when you're on
a team and it's like training camp and
you look around and you go we're about
to be a problem like can you just feel
it in the locker room
I think the mentality I think you build
them in Italian you know because you
gotta say like do OTAs you know training
camp like you build a comradery with the
team like everyone that like we're not
just playing together and just go to
work together but like we was really
hanging out going over each other house
is that rare kind of state brutal kind
of sort of because we assume that y'all
just chill all the time it's hard to
come into a locker room in you know for
me and Mike to kind of rub elbows and
understand like how he was raised and
how I was raised like being in a locker
room full of 53 and the visuals coming
from different you know prices in her
life like you might give somebody coming
from Iowa he comes from jr. I'm coming
from Los Angeles like it's different so
for us to have that camaraderie we had
and we was built like his his lady was
talking male like we was really doing
stuff in the community his kids might
like we did that stuff so it was really
like a brotherhood and we just felt we
had some special there for it to be gone
let's never finger
yeah tough man broke up so abruptly that
week it was like traumatized and I went
to New York he stayed shady state mac-11
went to Kansas City it was like in your
year if you had to sum it up in like one
sentence right like yeah I mean I'll
give a straight to you yeah real I would
just say it's like this so you have a
coach that comes in and brings in his
own stigma or his culture or there's
just love to see whatever you want to
call it right and he was one of the
coaches where he didn't believe in
players like it was his system and the
NFL's players that he wins championships
I don't get me wrong like a New England
Patriots they have a system that bill
better check his but they get upset
right
just feel like it's players in this
league like you have Tom Brady you have
Edelman you have Gronkowski you have all
these pieces instead of puzzle and Chip
Kelly was one of the coaches where he
was I guess my system it's like we like
literally when he was higher cut it like
that when he was hired him me McCoy
Macklin we didn't have starting
positions he was like y'all are be
agreement of fools but ya gotta earn
your position big battle is not a little
practice ball players yeah true story
just that year I'm laying in my
hyperbaric chamber before preseason game
I never told artists I'm battling Nick
Foles for a stomp position now I've been
the starter for 12 years of my career
now I'm in a battle which I'm clearly
winning nothing to gets Nick I was
nothing but respect for him we love him
to death I'm sending my hyperbaric
chamber with tears coming down my eyes
crying because I'm like I'm gonna do
everything I could for Chip Kelly I
didn't show them that that the
leadership play on the field speaks for
itself
galvanized the team when we had a tough
time you know with what happened with
Riley Cooper and I'm like there's still
not enough and it's just a reflection of
what the Sun is saying we we did
everything we could to show him that
we'll give you everything that we got
simple same and it was more about his
system and himself than us and that's
why we all just kinda broke that's
always but my belief is he didn't
realize he had the perfect player for
each position in his office and that you
can't just replace them with other
people it was never the system okay I
eat up